and remind me again what does that have
to do with the resurrection of
[Music]
Jesus Muslims and to the Christian
Brothers hello may God bless
you let us uh let us say they are Father
for I am not a Christian but let us say
it no we're not going to do that Scott
do you have any evidences offer us do
you have any evidence do you have any
evidence you can offer us against
uh by the way God logic uh I had no idea
that this lady in the chat was your your
fiance or wife I I I said something
inappropriate okay Scott Scott Scott do
you have any evidences against the
crucifixion one moment I want to
apologize to God Logic for
something I had no idea that uh that was
your wife so my
apologies it's okay we have no idea what
you're referring to so can you give us
evidences against the crucifixion
that's not what evidence against the
crucifixion yes uh okay yeah we're the
witness
records evidence against it can you
offer evidence against that is evidence
against
it where are the witness
records Josephus tacitus the four
gospels God referencing Josephus and
tasus Christian interpolations my God
God logic really these are the guys you
have up here come on so so Scott Scott
Scott so Scott if you're going to claim
that they are Christian interpolations
prove it why don't you do a Google
search as widely agreed by Christian
Scholars that they are interations then
go then go to shake Google and show
me okay we can go into christas pristas
we can go into the interpolations it's
widely agreed by Major biblical
SCH I want logic seriously these These
are the guys these are the guys God
logic you have up here God logic please
Scott Scott Scott we know you want ay's
attention just try to deal with the
topic I respect him more we know want
his attention you're not educated enough
on this topic then show us that you're
educated and give us proof of your
claims you just quoted two people who
are agreed by I stated their I stated
their names I didn't even quote them yet
prove it I stated their names and didn't
even quote them yet if you're going to
say that I can't quote them tell us why
give us proof it is agreed by Major
biblical scholars in modern day show oh
my God oh my God which part you might
call on your false god but your false
God isn't going to help you until he
gives you evidence it's literally it's
literally on the introduction of the
Wikipedia page so what are you do so so
what so what are you what are you why
don't you
Google Wikipedia bro so so so show me so
show so show
me Google go no you Google it if it's if
it's
theage on the wikip if it if it's the
front on the Wikipedia page then here
humor me show me the Wikipedia page yeah
you could Google Josephus Christian
interpolation I don't need tell trust me
bro I want you to prove it oh the reason
I don't want to discuss this is because
it's literally an agreed opinion among
biblical scholar and your ignorance is
not my problem your ignorance is not my
problem I'm ignorant so here how about
this you shut up I'll give you the
sources because I won't have to go to
Shay Google I'll go to an enemy of the
faith Bart
irman yeah B actually tells us that the
testimony in flavianum
is
true a part of it for example let's look
at let's look at what he says let's look
at what he says in Bart man's book did
Jesus exist page
60 he finds an early Arabic manuscript
which is translated in John mayor's book
The marginal Jew which shows us an
authentic rendition of the testimonium
flavianum and here is what Josephus
actually said at this time there was a
wise man who was called Jesus and his
conduct was good and he was known to be
virtuous and many people from among the
Jews and other nations came to be his
disciples pilate condemned him to be
crucified and to be un alived and those
who had become his disciples did not
abandon their loyalty to him they
reported that he had appeared to them 3
days after his crucifixion and that he
was Al liive accordingly they believed
that he was the Messiah concerning whom
the prophet of recounted Wonders so are
you going to argue
against this is Lally the same account
Scott Scott this is literally the same
account this is literally the same
account this literally the same you've
literally quoted the same account did
not quote the I did not quote the the
rendition of the testimonium flavan
because the teson flavum begins there
once was a man or should we dare even to
call him a man it literally calls Jesus
the Messiah and it says it doesn't say
anything about the disciples believing
that Jesus rose from the dead so to say
that I quoted the exact testimony of
flavianum and not the Arabic text which
is rendered by Bart er's book in his
book Jesus did Jesus exist is completely
laughable and shows that you have no
idea what you're talking about so just
because some words are not exactly the
same it is nearly 90% you said I quoted
it verbatim
yes I was saying that is it is
practically the same so you're lying
again no you're playing word games
you're playing word games I'm holding
you to your own words what I clearly
said was that it was practically the
same account which does not mean it is
exactly the same account so are you
going to be an honest say practically
the are you going to be are you going to
are you going to be an honest debator
are you going to be an honest debator or
are you going to do your little game
your little Tik Tok debate game so me
actually so me actually giving the
evidence in front of us and quoting my
sources is being dishonest and playing
the Tik Tok so let's look up the
supposed
Arabic Arabic
manuscript that that's what that is not
that is 90% the same as the
interpolation Greek manuscript and let's
look into that and see is this a
trustworthy account yes this is what I
quoted and John Bear's book a marginal
Jew would you like to look up the
book I'm looking it up right now in the
backround yeah go ahead look up John
mayor's book a marginal
[Music]
Jew and go to Pages go to pages
59-69 so you are using this as evidence
he was crucified and resurrected right
right yes that that Jesus was crucified
not particularly that that he was
resurrected but the particular issue
that we're having first and foremost is
the crucifixion which is what we asked
you
about
okay
great so this
work
is it seems to be predating the
interpolations so we can work from
that this work is from which
century the 10th
century when I CED up when I CED up I
asked
you do you have any witness
records your witness record your witness
record
is do you know the men do you know
before before before I'm familiar with
before you continue let me ask you this
question what are the records how how
early from what century do we have the
earliest
manuscripts of
josephus's testimony all of his
testimony of his of his history of the
Jews what century do we find the
earliest manuscript do be the actual
earliest physical
manuscripts
yes bro they come several centuries
after Christ Josephus the 10 the 10th
Century the same Century that we find
the earliest rendition of the testimony
Flav so if you're going to
say that these are so these are too late
then you don't know anything about
Jewish history to begin with you don't
know anything about first and second we
don't know anything about we don't if
you don't know anything jism because it
comes from
Josephus you very clearly and by the way
Josephus mentions Jesus in passing very
peculiar and everyone knows this is very
peculiar because he was such a
meticulous person I asked you for
witness accounts of the crucifixion do
you know what a witness account is do
you know what a witness to a robbery is
hell you're refer so you're referring to
ey so you're referring to eyewitness
accounts if you're referring to
eyewitness accounts we can go to the
four
gospels the four
gospels we can go we can go to we can go
to Bart erman's quote about the four
gospels being used as independent
historical sources for by the way by the
by by the way where he says in his book
did Jesus exist page
74 once it is conceded that the gospels
can and should be treated as historical
sources no different from other
historical sources infused with their
own author's biases it starts to become
clear why historians have almost
universally agreed that whatever else
what might say about him Jesus of
Nazareth lived in first century
Palestine and was crucified by the
prefect of Judea within the first
century we have four independent
accounts of Jesus's life and death so
they are historical eyewitness accounts
your argument your argu this is why you
are so insincere your argument is to
quote Bart Urban himself in his own
books now let's extrapolate the four
gospels we know they are based on one
another
so so so if you're going to
make God logic God logic God logic God
logic is is your friend here sincere is
he is he
sincere so are you going to prove the
claim that the gospels are relying on
each
other God logic is he is he being
sincere is he being sincere right
now because you you know what he just
said is false right
so quoting just the scholars is being
dishonest right now yes because you have
to rely on you haveing the scholars is
dishonest ladies and gentlemen because
what you quoted instead
of bro don't appeal to the audience
don't appeal to the audience what you
just quoted what you just quoted to what
you just quoted in Bart Urban okay was
just complete generic nonsense the the
quote you just quoted so are you are are
you going to let me finish are you going
to let me finish or are you going to
interrupt because you are a
woman so oh so so I'm a woman now listen
so so anyone who interrupts you is now a
woman is that kind of sexist I am a
sexist so listen dang I mean your argu
your
arguments your argument and uh listen
your argument was basically like your
Prophet your argument who Prophet you
know you don't even know what religion I
am your argument your argument was to
literally quote a generic passage in
Bart IR which literally appealed to no
uh real references it was literally just
a passage where Bart says we can accept
that these four gospel accounts are
independent sources and eyewitness
accounts that's literally what the court
was that you said okay so their
eyewitness accounts now literally now
literally that is not an argument you
realize that right so so their
eyewitness accounts
listen listen you have a you don't even
see eyewitness accounts right you are
quoting Bart Urban making that claim
you're appealing to Authority ey witness
accounts even admitted by the enemies of
Christianity according to Bart Man do
you not see the mistake and logic you're
making you're appealing to
Authority refering
gu I'm referring to the
Christi so inere stop yelling I'm
referring to the enemies of Christianity
even
conceeding the point that the
gospels are independent iwitness
accounts and even from a secular
perspective they are referring to the
unanimous testimony of
scholarship so I'm actually to SCH I'm
actually quoting Scholars I'm
quoting refer to the scholarship that he
is referring to I'm I'm
speaking so I've actually provided
scholarship I've provided sources what
is the evidence that you
have to argue against the points that
I've made that Jesus was crucified
what's your source that testifies that
Jesus was not crucified
yeah very simply the account from
Josephus comes 1,000 years later okay
that's the earliest body skp recording
of this supposed crucifixion uh the
crucifixion
was goels aren't
earli the crucifixion was fabricated and
compiled in the second century and of
course a 10th
Century
manuscript what what's your what's your
that
your so what's your first century
where's your first century I already I
already told you the four gospels so we
have already have four of them you have
no first C papus you have no first
century papus stop yelling stop yelling
dude
breathe so what is your proof that the
crucifixion was invented in the 2
Century what is your first or second
century source to back that claim
up where is the first century
Source I will ask the question again if
there is no first
century first cury sourcea the last time
Scott so what is your source to prove
your claim that the CH that that the
crucifixion was invented in the 2
Century what's your what's your
proof the fact that there's no first
century account of
it there is not there is not a single ey
witness account in the first century of
the crucifixion so what is your proof
that it was made up in the second
century question I have a question if
we're just going to go with this type of
thinking um what is your uh what is your
seventh century Source
manuscript um about Muhammad's
visitation in the cave
what the visitation the visitation of
the GI listen we both know listen we
choose to believe what we believe and
you choose to believe or you believe
it's all it's all magical thinking
anyway listen let's just be honest let's
be real let's be real let's be real
let's be real stop what is your
eyewitness
Source what there is no eyewitness
except the
prophet so if you're saying that um
you're a you're a acknowledging that you
don't have any type of uh 7th Century
document or eyewitness testimony to
Muhammad's visitation of the cave yet
you still believe it and believe it's
still valid he is the
eyewitness where where does Muhammad
talk about this and I need to I need a
source from Muhammad himself that dates
back to the 7th Century from himself uh
talking about how he got a visitation
from uh from Gabriel Gabriel and I want
him to
thought that I'm not going to lie here
in claim that I have it to
memory but but but I but I I I have to
memory certain sources from his Etc
accounting have to go you said you would
have to go to the Hadith is that correct
yeah yeah I'd have I'd have to check I
don't have to what what is the earliest
manuscript of any Hadith that you
have of the Hadith yeah uh earliest oh
wait wait wait do you mean physical copy
first manuscript work yes it it comes
about a century to two centuries after
not one century two centuries 200 years
later so that's your earliest so you
have you don't even have uh something
that's in the time of Muhammad from
Muhammad about his own experience uh in
the cave yet you still believe it you
still believe it's valid but FAL
trying let me land it you're trying to
force a criteria on us and the
Christians
by saying that we need first century in
the time of Jesus papy physical
manuscript in order to have an
eyewitness account of the crucifixion or
or what was going okay so okay
understand your point no no it's not
hypocrisy notice one second I'm going to
respond to everyy I'm going to respond
to Avery it's not hypocrisy uh we have
the first century purat okay you have
the
person the
Quan Where where in the qurat does it
say that the angel Gabriel came to
Muhammad in the cave here it talks about
the message entering his heart it
doesn't say Muhammad's heart oh come on
don't give give me the first Cent give
me the seventh century manuscript that
says that the that the Revelation came
to Muhammad's heart and specifically
give me the first century manuscript of
the Quran seventh century guys is what
he means by first Cent what the first
century of Muhammad of Islam give me the
first the sth century manuscript of the
Quran that talks about Muhammad's
visitation in the cave from
Gabriel I'll have to I'm going to look
into right it doesn't exist there is no
first century manuscript of the Quran
well it doesn't matter because during
that time the prophet raised an army all
of which were filled with all of which
were filled all of which were with
scribes all of which were filled withas
all of which were filled
with you see logic it don't matter with
it don't matter with him apparently
because hold on hold on Scott I'm
speaking please so it don't matter with
Scott cuz he's a Muslim and he and
apparently Muhammad had hundreds of
thousands of scribes an army of scribes
just putting it all down writing it all
down but even with that army of scribes
we ain't even got a single first century
manuscript and apparently that doesn't
matter but for us which is affirm when
we actually have sources we should
affirmed by people who are not Muslim
that are first century iwitness
accounts apparently even when we even
when we do have those apparently we
don't and even when we
don't theci have here I have the script
manuscript isn't from the first century
no no the sa manuscript is very early I
think it is 7th Century or 8th Century
one of those it's very early it's very
early however the son of manuscript has
Eraser on it people was going in editing
it you can literally see the Eraser on
the manuscripts and it's different it
says different things than what your
what Your Quran says today oh the beauty
of science because we are able to
validate and clarify
we're able to we're able to valid we're
able to validate and clarify the Eraser
correct really where do you do that what
you just said you just said you just
said you just said you just said it
yourself how you how can you shows
evence that things are marked that
things are erased and something is
written on top of it it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter we were talking we
were talking we were talking about we
were talking about
you can't keep cutting him off dude let
him talk please he getting annoying yes
you keep interrupting black doctor when
he's speaking dude let him it's two
against one give me you don't want to
talk you don't want to talk to me but
you still keep talking over me dude
that's the problem apologies so again
you can only you you can't look and see
what's erased you can only look and see
what's on top of it so the claim that we
can know what's erased is completely
false you don't know how you don't know
how this works that's that's irrelevant
the topic that Avery brought up let me
you're not letting me you're not letting
me you're not let me finish the point
you're not letting me finish the point
you're not letting me finish the point a
read the point the point the point Avery
raised was about the matter of The
Descent of the Quran and anything about
the prophet's Revelation the S
manuscript does contain verses related
to the Quran percent okay
yes it does okay show me the show me the
verse in the son of manuscript that says
Gabriel came to Muhammad in the cave of
her
here now I'm going to check whether it
references specifically the agel Gabriel
okay I don't know if it does reference
that particularly but I do know that it
references the the the the bringing down
of the Quran bro you don't even you
don't even have in your Quran today a
reference of the cave of H and Muhammad
in the beh yeah you don't that's not in
the Quran at
all he's grasping at straws logic but
let him know I'm not grasping at straws
he brought up a particular topic which
was The Descent of the Quran okay now
ially said Gabriel's visitation of
Muhammad in the cave of Hera that's what
I
said bar enough I'm not aware if the
salt does contain that the specific
reference of the
it not even not even your Quran today
your Quran today does not contain that
that reference that comes from the Hadi
that come 200 years after the
fact the Quran references The Descent
okay it may not reference the particular
method that is why we utilize the Hadith
and the Quran in culmination with one
another so so so so going to tell me
that it is okay for you as a Muslim to
not have any uh early documentation on
Muhammad's visitation in the cave no
eyewitness testimony but you still
believe it and you count it as valid but
it's not good for the Christian to have
second century
manuscripts uh relating back to the
first century events of what happened
written by Matthew Mark Luke and johnop
iies of these references combined with
the church fathers who followed the
apostles who has Apostolic succession
Bishops uh uh and church Bishop uh
succession all of this history and oral
transmission combined with the text and
manuscript that we have that's not okay
but it's okay for you to have 200 years
after the fact combined with oral
tradition and you know just I guess you
know um yes but you are leaving you yeah
but you're leaving a particular thing do
you see do you see the
inconsistency if if you are look if you
are looking at things superficially you
could see the inconsistency but you are
but but but but you are leaving a
particular thing out which is that your
your your Bible your gospels are the
Hadith
weag imagine if our man if our
manuscripts of the Gospel
came 200 years later imagine what you
would be saying to us literally your
gospels do come 200 years later no they
don't they they come around they come WR
in the first they're written in the
first century and the copies that we
have are not even 100 years later the
copies that we have are within 100 years
yours are not even within 100 years it's
200 plus years later your gospels are
equivalent to our correct no it's better
than yourth better than your Quran in
ter in terms of understanding that they
are accounts of sayings Etc yes if
you're talking about it's historical
genre sure are you saying the Quran yes
yes yes
okay historical genre okay where is your
Quran my it's been corrupted no no no no
no
no where is your Quran this additional
resour where is your Quran the
additional the additional resource the
word from God it's been corrupted this
is
why do not do not do not play games
you're playing games though I'm not
where where is the accompanying book
from God that that matches up to your
gospel dude it's been corrupted that's
the point origal Quan the original Quran
that accompanied the the Bible you know
that Muhammad brought in Arabia has been
corrupted it's we don't have any access
to it anymore that's the
[Music]
point God logic I don't understand what
what the hell you are saying here really
I'm asking you about the Christian
equivalent of the Quran where where is
the point I'm outlining here is that the
inconsistencies you brought up are valid
valid to bring up however what we have
is an additional resource which is the
Quran which
add it it's it's it's it's it's the
source text and then you have the Hadith
which are the sayings accompanying it
you only have the sayings accompanying
nothing no that's
that's goels the source we have the
source text the text if you want to talk
about uh the sayings accompanying it
then that would be our church fathers
and the apostolic succession that would
be the H equivalent while the Bible is a
source document no no no no
yes your no no your uh your church
fathers would be equivalent to the in
Islam no no yes yes because there's
quote they're quoting the apostles and
they're quoting Jesus saying Jesus said
this Jesus said this Apostle said this
Apostle said that Apostle uh uh uh knew
this person and knew that person right
that's that's just like the Hadith yeah
yeah yeah they're quoting Jesus from the
the
gospels they're they're Jesus from from
the go Testament is the Gospel of Jesus
bro so the New Testament is the Gospel
of Jesus yes fantastic that's why they
had to copy each
other well this is my
thing that's why they had to copy that's
why they had to copy to the because
because accusation you're talking over
right now you could you could throw all
type of accusation and stuff but that
doesn't deal with the incons cons no but
you're running a wi you're running stop
trying to be inconsistent all the only
reason why I even came up here was
because I saw you applying an
inconsistent criteria to Black doctor
that you yourself don't even hold to so
in this
conversation okay I agree that on the
face of it on a high level you can look
at what I'm saying and see say it is
inconsistent however I would say to that
we have multiple resources one which we
believe is wholly complete which
accompanies the Hadith which I believe
equivalent to your gospels and I don't
believe you have this single source of
Truth which accompanies your gospels
okay we can agree to disagree okay we
can agree to disagree on this matter at
the end of the day what's the that's
that's the question so you you can say
that what is your evidence against the
testimony that are in the gospel that we
have what what's your
evidence which one in particular the
crucifixion yeah the crucifixion and the
resurrection any of this any of this
what we've been on about for like an
hour bro okay okay okay listen do you
know why it's actually kind of hard to
argue against the crucifixion okay
because you have literally
no one second it's like hear me out here
I'm not attacking Christianity I have a
lot of actually love for you guys it's
like it's it's it's it's like it's like
let's say there's a Shakespearean play
and there are three acts in the play and
you and and someone comes along and says
this second act never happened it
doesn't make sense because without the
second act there is no third act and
that's kind of the way I look at
Christianity all right it's a it's it's
a
it's it's it's a reality mixed in with a
theater play okay and it doesn't make if
someone comes along to you I could
totally understand why if I said to you
the crucifix never happen it's like me
saying act two of this play Never
Happened it doesn't make any sense cuz
then act three can happen the
resurrection so to you it's logically
like it's logically impossible okay it's
logically impossible it doesn't add up
okay so we can wh waful back and forth
with each other all day but if I keep I
it doesn't matter how hard I try to
convince you the crucifixion ever
happened because because in doing so it
erupts the resurrection and everything
else about Christianity well if if you
if you disprove the crucifiction by
default there is no resurrection and in
Christianity it's impossible it's
impossible to outright using Christ
using Christian logic or regular debate
logic to uh disprove the crucifixion the
fact of the matter is it's a matter of
faith and belief it's not a matter it's
a matter of faith and belief I choose to
accept Islam into my heart and I choose
to believe I choose to believe it didn't
happen okay I got so so this is what you
said so far so and and what you said is
is are no logical you know
historical um objections that you can
bring against the crucifixion and
Resurrection it comes down to a blind
faith what you choose to believe and put
your faith in and you choose to believe
and put your faith in the claim that it
didn't happen because you're a Muslim
and you know you follow the Quran so I
mean thank you for saying that I I agree
with you that that's what you have to
rely on because you can't
logically um imp empirically evidently
go against the crucifixion and
resurrection of Jesus you can't do it
yeah but but can you clarify be honest
that that's not because you know can I
clarify what can you clarify that's not
a failure that's not because that's a
failure on my part it is can you can you
can can you concede that you believe in
it as a matter of Faith too if you can
concede that we can have an honest
convers we could have conversation let
let me tell you how we see faith is is
differently because there's a difference
a blind faith which is you believe in
something without evidence or really
logic and you just choose to believe
this particular thing and then there's
Faith with substance which is what what
the Bible says the Bible says faith is
the substance of things hoped for the
evidence of Things Not Seen that's the
type of faith that I have I'm choosing
to trust the evidence and the substance
that has been provided to me so I'm
saying there's evidence and substance
behind Jesus being crucified and
resurrected and I'm choosing to believe
the evidence
you have Blind Faith so that's where
we're
different oh my oh my God come on come
on you you choose to you choose to
believe that the gospels are perfect
perfect in their original Greek Etc
because there's no no no no no someone
who's an atheist can come along and
present to you according to atheistic
criteria and scientific rationalist
criteria objectively reasonable evidence
that certain elements are corrupted or
interpolations Etc you choose on Blind
Faith to deny that so I don't listen I
respect you but I don't I don't
appreciate you're I don't let me finish
let me can I just finish I don't
appreciate that you're contextualizing
it as you have evidence-based faith and
I have Blind Faith the objective truth
the objective truth is that you and I
both have Blind Faith you and I both
have Blind Faith that is the objective
truth what is your evidence and I and I
and I and I say that with all sincerity
if you can't be sincere with me what is
your what is your evidence that I have
Blind Faith because you choose to
believe the gospel is Holy when I just
explained to you that scientific
evidence that I'm believing in it
blindly because there are many
reasonable atheist rationalist arguments
as to why certain go pieces of the
gospels are actually later
interpolations yeah but what what is
your evidence that I'm not using
perfectly reasonable rational local uh
uh reasons to believe the evidence that
back up the Bible because their evidence
out where your evidence like
what uh listen we can we can go into
this I'll give you one example I'll give
you one example I'll give you one
example I'll give you one example it's
it's agree today listen I'm not I'm not
trying to run away it's just because it
would take too long it's agreed today
for example that the story of the
adulteress is an interpolation later
okay
the story by who agreed upon by who the
story of the adulterous of John is a
later Christian interpretation yes or no
uh no but but okay you see we we all
this discussion we kind all this
discussion we all this discussion Scott
watch this let me even give you that so
we're talking about atheistic
non-believer arguments right Bart IR who
acknowledges the text variant including
that even thinking that it's a a later
interpolation he says it has no effect
on the biblical Theology and theme of
The Bible okay now Bart Urban a guy you
previously quoted you're quoting one
second and now you're quoting again he
says that that particular uh
story is is an interpretation yes he's
an atheist that says that the very that
are in the scriptures including that one
has no effect on the message and theme
of The Bible yes yes yes it has no
effect but he says it's an interpolation
yes it's of not it's of no consequence
but does he concede it's an
interpolation yes or no he believes that
it's a later Edition okay so you have
referenced him before to back him up so
now if you're referencing him again that
means you agree with him that's an
interation yes or no no Scott over your
hand yes I don't know I understand the
point you made but do you AG what's the
point that I made stop what's the point
that I made the point was that it has no
bearing on biblical theology no no no
that's not even my point that's not see
that's why I'm saying it's going over
your head your entire argument right now
is that the atheist The Atheist argument
is is uh full of substance and is more
um you know more evident than my than my
position I have Blind Faith while
particular bringing rational arguments
so you brought
up things comut me off man so you
brought about atheists can show us that
the Bible is not reliable and so what
I've done is is I've quoted an atheist a
new testament critic who's an atheist
who even says that even what you brought
up has no effect on biblical
authenticity so originally we originally
you claimed that you believe based on
faith with evidence and that I believe
yeah I feel like you're
not I understand what you said but I'm
going to light it up again because I
feel like you
have the point point of what I just said
Scott you've manipulated things no
what's the point of what I just said
Scott tell me the point of what you just
said I just I just gave it to you he
just told you yes the point you made was
that even an
atheist who uses a according to me
better arguments related to the evidence
has said it has no relation to the
biblical theology okay now now now can I
say something now that is not what we
were talking about we were talking about
belief in the gospels as a whole okay so
you choose to believe in something which
that person who you CAU in reference
agrees as an interpolation you choose to
believe it anyway yes or no it doesn't
matter what about the whole overarching
biblical theology you choose to believe
certain apies despite evidence overing
biblical theology is intact that it's
the exact same like when you interact
like when you interview Bart Erman
you're mixing two when you cause him to
be honest he he when you ask him what do
you think the New Testament actually
says he says well exactly what it says
now he literally says that we are just
tinkering with the text in referring to
textual criticism
it says exactly what it's supposed to
say you're you're making two different
arguments and mixing them together on
the one hand you're making the argument
that you're using factual evidence that
happened and then on the other hand
you're making the argument that it has
no bearing on the overall biblical
theology we were originally talking
about argument one which was factual
evidence now you're changing the AR
against the crucifixion of Jesus yeah
now you're changing the argument from
real factual evidence of things that
happened to being now a debate about the
overarch biblical
theology we were
never stop how I mean man we're we're
human beings how does someone like you
miss what you just said you're the one
who brought this up you said that we are
that that atheists are using better
arguments with substance and and
evidence and facts while we as
Christians are not believing stuff based
on facts like the crucifixion for
example I asked you to give me an
example of this you said well well um
they they agree that you know the Bible
has interpretations like like the uh the
adulterous woman well I gave you an
atheist that says that has no effect on
the facts of and authentic authenticity
of the Bible you brought this up and I
just proved you wrong yeah but it it
does prend to the authenticity of that
story yes so no no it doesn't
so no I no you made the clip is not my
source because there's other Scholars
that argue for the adulterous woman so I
AR brought brought man to give you an
example of even if an atheist says this
he's still saying that the Bible is
still all
things so you deny completely that you
have Blind Faith whatsoever
whatsoever and
we and guess what and guess what you
Blind Faith you have Blind Faith that I
have Blind Faith that's what I was
showing you the fact the the fact that
you're saying that I have Blind Faith is
coming from a position of Blind Faith
you have no evidence that I have Blind
Faith uh Hey logic there you just give
evidence yourself one word there is one
word to
describe what Scott is doing to you
right now and that word is called
projection because he has Blind Faith he
can't live with himself said it myself
it's projection if I ad I know I know I
know I know you just said it but since
you can't live with yourself because you
have that you're going to have to make
yourself feel better that Avery does too
that's false it's actually better to
live this way than to live in a way
where you're always questioning the
evidence and blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah going on better to live that
way you said that it's better to live
that way other than question the
evidence presented what what
it is yes moral yes because question
everything except for Islam is what I'm
to listen it is better better to live in
Blind
Faith it's better to live in Blind Faith
than evidence presented wow because I I
got a second would you tell anyone of
the the the Jews who accepted the Ten
Commandments who is better a Jew who
believes blindly in the Ten Commandments
and follows them or a Jew who questions
them every day
who question who is objectively better
who is objectively better who is
objectively
better trying to answer the question
Scott you won't stop repeating it it's
all right it's all right guys um hey
Scott thanks for coming up I'm going
ahead let the next guest come up man
that's fine God logic may God bless you
listen I want you to answer but but can
you answer before I go which Jew is
objectively better and more moral the
Jew who believes blindly in the Ten
Commandments or the Jew who questions
them every day the Jew don't have to
believe blindly is more objectively
moral to do with their morality the
question doesn't even make any sense
they don't even have to believe blindly
in the Ten Commandments they have them
to to read what are you talking about
but even but even then guys someone who
announ who who looks at the Ten
Commandments and looks at where they
come from and trues their Source back to
Moses and to the god yah play who does
as the bereans do who study the
scriptures to see whether these things
are true they are commended in scripture
so the Bible tells us who is more who
who is more
reliable the blind fath someone who just
says hey let's go worship other gods or
the person who tests the prophets like
God commanded them to yeah I think we
just got another new quote today uh
logic it's better to believe blindly
than to test evidence presented wow I
love that somebody somebody quote that
somebody put that on a t-shirt Muslim
logic